give me your phone what are you looking
for i'm worried about you who's this
[ __ ] right here
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god i
[Music]
is in the air the pumpkins are in the
patch and our friends at manscape are
here to make sure you don't carve your
pants pumpkins when you're grooming very
important if you know what i'm saying of
course you do
make sure you're keeping things fresh
this fall with the leaders in male
grooming and their brand new fourth
generation performance package boys get
ready for a cuffing season like no other
ready to take the leap into fall with
manscape join the 2 million men
worldwide using manscape by going to
manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with code
omghi that's oh my god hi
a lot of new sports that didn't exist
back then
we you know i mean
there's a lot of sports there's chicks
and bikinis and there's did you ever go
see highlight
yeah it's still around
run by the mob it's still around they
come over and they go what would you
like the score to be i used to love it i
used to like watch it what do you mean
would i like the score to be no no you
put we notice you put a lot of money
down what do you want the score to be
how much how much do you want to win by
no no we go without them oh okay
the i used to go and we used to go see
him at me i mean it was a big sport
i was huge still around the basks the
best and uh
with that long and that hard ball like
camacho
i've seen like stills but i've never
seen actual footage oh it was awesome
it still exists in miami it's called um
but now they also got paramutual uh
gaming in the place which is what keeps
them
surviving yeah
are we going aaron
we're going we're into it
um
did you hang out had you read the
article had you read the the instantes
poem
no okay
i had did he ever get the poem out no
what was it what was he impressed by
in a think tank a chicano in a think
tank
yeah
and then you go in there because
somebody says hey
we're all rich what are we missing
no i think that's what i'm thinking
what are we doing we've done everything
right what can we what can we do wrong
uh is that what it is what's the purpose
of a think tank just to get minds like
they should let people into you know
melania trump came into this country
intelligence yeah oh god help us
[Laughter]
but there is a visa you can give to
somebody
if you can't live without them
they can come into this country
sweetheart let me just tell you
something for you to be uh put into a
think tank in colorado you would need a
special immigrant visa i wouldn't that
would be like
before we start what's he doing here
you know i i um
i think my intelligence comes from
my neurons
[Laughter]
which have survived a lot of
things i think eventually you make it
you make so many mistakes when it comes
back around you go well i'm not doing
that [ __ ] twice
so maybe you would make enough where you
start to learn
there's a school of hard knocks which
isn't which is not in colorado yeah but
here's my my fear though is
that
with all the with life and age and
alcohol then urine start dying and you
forget
the the bad turns you've taken and you
take them again do you think that my
grandmother had dementia
do you think
if she didn't watch tv as much as she
did and did something that actually
stimulates her mind that she would
have not had that or
are you genetically prone to
whatever causes it i'm not sure what
causes it i don't know but if you're
genetically prone you should be uh [ __ ]
scared right now you don't you don't
have uh they don't have enough
information on still an unknown i wrote
a paper on uh
uh dementia and alzheimer's because it
is is uh what does what do they call it
back in the disability like if you say
something oh yeah it just used to be
senility they're getting old now there
is it's not even
uh predisposed now they're saying there
may be some kind of new science where
they can go ahead and tell you if you're
going to be predisposed to it but it's
not hereditary
uh what about living in a house that's
120 degrees when it's 110 outside
burning calories
for old people there's a lot no early
onset
i know
uh twin sisters that uh passed away in
their forties
there was a homicide cop both of them
had it yeah
uh maybe they bumped maybe they ran into
each other when they were little
they have matching like
a homicide cop same thing they thought
he was just getting lazy he wasn't doing
his work as it turned out in his 50s he
did he got it and he needed to pass away
from it
that's what what happened he held freeze
and then he didn't move yeah
he stopped himself
that's a horrible [ __ ] joke you know
i was the last one i was the last one
that my grandmother uh
i thought why couldn't i
paying for all go first
[Music]
where am i at you're a serious palace
she's in the same room
yeah you're in italy
she didn't know
i should have put her in i really should
have put her in a home when you think
about
did she live to see your success
well she pretended she didn't see it
some of it i don't know what she
considered success
being quiet to her was be if i was quiet
she would say
you're quiet
and that for her that was success what
do you consider success
um
[Music]
that's a good question i love to do this
oh yeah man i'm looking at this better
dr phil that's a good question what do i
consider well
being that i'm emotionally dead inside i
think
having a car that starts right away and
then the garage door opening
and not getting locked out of my house i
think that's a success
i think having freedom to make choices i
think freedom is a success right
and
and freedom to make choices doesn't just
mean
economic freedom even though the
economic freedom is a big one right
because when you don't when you don't
have money you don't have freedom to
make some choices
do you have
do you have early onset dementia i might
no we weren't talking about this we
weren't somebody was talking about that
was it today
well i probably shouldn't be doing this
but
i'm not going to remember anyway the
last three neurons are staring at each
other right now
you know my grandmother worried about
everything but self-imposed worrying
but i think i think i think that's very
i first i think that comes with age with
some you know some because my mom has
this you would say i worry about you i'm
like
don't you're gonna make something bad
happen to me well if you were mania
though i'd worry about you too you
wouldn't that's what by the way it's
good to have somebody worry about you
don't you think don't you miss that
having somebody worry about you
by worrying you mean up your ass 24
hours a day or whatever
no like actually giving a [ __ ] if you
don't show up like you know what
what what have i told you give me your
phone give me your phone what are you
looking for i'm worried about you who's
this [ __ ] right here
he does he does care about others though
i was late to uh a show late to a taping
a few weeks ago and instead of being
someone that would call up say hey where
you at
where are you when you're going to get
here what's going on
short message
all this said was hey gil are you okay
yeah he was concerned about me it wasn't
because i was late
and
so he does care about others somebody
does care he cares about others
he likes he doesn't he doesn't get
concerned when i'm late because he knows
that i'm you know an entitled hispanic
from miami she's amazing yeah we don't
we don't do we don't do punctuation
listen it's a different vibe over there
than it is here that's why when i
reached out to her because of my
curiosity over seeing her
withstand the slings and arrows of every
pundit from
from right to left to and when i saw her
filing her nails when someone was going
i was seeing everything
she's doing right now she's doing it
right now i was like this woman is not
only
funny
she's smart
and
has never stammered or stuttered or
searched for a word it was always there
and i thought this i'm a performer
i see it and i'm like this person
while you're giving
her [ __ ] she's got you she's already got
you
like in the terminator when you walk in
and they put it in and they got all the
stuff and they know what you're about
already so finish so i can
put you in your place exactly
and i said i called a senator a center
of dm and i said you know what what's
the company lying on on immigration i
thought she i didn't know she was
republican
and
we became
like i love her i yeah i love being
around her i love she makes me laugh she
gives people [ __ ] she gives me [ __ ]
she's just
and it's beautiful
because it's because it's not it's
i don't even want to say anything it's
just love that's how you well but you
know what it is too and i really i think
this is the key to life like every
aspect authenticity you've got to be
whether you're
uh being funny on a you know in a comedy
stage whether you are on tv giving
opinions whether you are in a friendship
whether you're in a marriage whether you
know you've got to be authentic you've
got to be who you are because it gets it
gets tiresome and burdensome
if uh if it's not if the feeling is not
authentic has there been anybody that's
ever put you in a place where that made
you feel uncomfortable or that maybe
personal or not in your family or
anything
in my family that made me feel
uncomfortable you know i'm not close to
my sister and that really sucks because
my my brother passed away so you know
and it's like every time i think about
it i keep thinking i hope i run into him
in heaven assuming i go there so i can
kick his ass for dying and leaving me in
this world with just my sister to deal
with all of this stuff you know
is it sibling or is it is it
when one you know
i think it's more common than
than not that and you're blood but
you're two people wired different you
have no siblings i don't have any
siblings but two people are wired
different they don't talk or when you
see them together in a room the dynamic
changes just because they're together in
the room or i mean i came from a place
where the family wasn't close but the
people around them in families and in my
family would call up and say
is so-and-so still there yeah he's
getting ready to leave okay call me when
he leaves so i can come over and not
even risk the chance of running into
somebody so what would you do like on
family holidays and you know baptisms
and all these things and
what what do you
drink it wasn't no no it just wasn't
unfortunate i've never never had that
problem and i come from a family of six
sisters
and
you know we really don't want to hear
about functional things
if you're about to tell us about how you
love your six sisters
sisters and me isn't there a song
i've only been around her for 10 minutes
and i love her already because you're
right the humor the articulation
right there hey who are you putto
tell us about how everybody in your
family loves each other
hey when i just started talking to her
she goes do you live alone you know
you're going to die upstairs at the
dogs don't know how to call
about yeah 911 should be i i check in on
you all the time because i'm afraid
that that you know
that that the smell of my body's gonna
bring people to the house before that
lady just on the news she was in the
hospital with covet and she came home
only to find her husband dead yeah
so so so
in the big world
why why are people
what do they think that they're putting
a chip into the net why are they on
backs and backs and and and now when we
thought well i don't know if we're
making the head now we're going in the
now we're going in the wrong direction
again
is there a simple answer to that no no
i mean look there's some you know
there's some people who are anti-vaxxers
regardless of partisanship regardless of
politics i mean there's people you know
there's people last name kennedy uh so
regardless of economic social status
there are some people who are
anti-vaxxers uh there's some people who
had issues because of the fda approval
which is no longer an issue as of the
last
seven days and then listen the truth is
this thing got politicized from day one
the mask wearing got politicized somehow
it's gotten turned into some
ridiculous notion of a crusade for
uh
privacy and and freedoms
do you know how many freedoms you give
up on a daily basis in order to keep the
world secure
i mean would you have ever thought
20 years ago september 10th 20 years ago
that you would be taking off your shoes
and your belt and your shirt and your
this and getting patted down and having
an x-ray why do you you know why do they
tell what why do we not drink and drive
to keep ourselves safe and to keep
others safe why don't why do we put
children in
in
car seats to keep the kids safe i mean
what why do we drive at the speed limit
right or all around or around there you
know approximately i mean it's you know
so there's all these issues
how many i mean you have a you know you
have a kid your kid had to have a
shitload of vaccines in order to go to
school that's right
and all of us or even shots when they're
born like they say this at this date and
this date in this state and no one could
ever sit there like we're not gonna do
that what do you mean you're gonna
you're not gonna give your kid the shots
and you go and they go and you go and
you go and then they've had their shots
even a dog
yeah your dog can't come over here and
stay here while you travel because your
dog hasn't had its shots and your dog's
not going to be in this place because
these dogs have had their shots they've
had their back they are up to date and
your dog can't come in
and nobody thinks anything about that
i get listen whenever my dog flies with
me
i uh and she's a five pound poodle did
you think about bringing your dog to
hawaii
even though you know you couldn't did
you did you think about say cha cha cap
sorry i have to give you this pill but
when you get to mom when we get to maui
i'm gonna show you a good way
listen
you know that [ __ ] can't quarantine she
would have killed her and killed me yeah
yeah she's a diva is a five pound poodle
uh she's lost weight during cover so
she's the only member of the household
very rare
she's a sweet dog and so you can't bring
a pet to hawaii
let me tell you how i just got back from
hawaii and they are so strict when it
comes to and rightly so because you know
they're very strained on resources
they're very strict when it comes to the
covert vaccines uh they just arrested a
couple from florida
like a fake card or something like that
or can you imagine
to hawaii from florida okay you guys
have it five hours away right you're
coming from florida you're talking
brother you're talking
11 hours
with a layover so you're paying a ton of
money you're spending all this time on a
plane and you can't go get a vaccine
right
which is free yeah they falsified their
they went to jail yes yeah so you're
paying money to buy a fake vaccine card
and then i mean that's just crazy
i think they're selling fake vaccine
cards
because
you can buy fake anything today yeah
i don't know what you want you can buy a
fake
by the way did you see the ladies lips
that was on the table next to us last
night
speaking of fake yeah they were fake
but
not proportioned to
what what is the psychology of
of having these two huge red and then
when she got up she was dressed like she
was 20 and she was 60. well that's
exactly the psychology don't you
remember how plump and luscious lips
were when you were young and then it's
like you know it's the only thing that
gets skinnier with age is your lips they
do right they do
when that was important
when i was when i was cougar on the
prowl i've gotten smaller when i was a
kid
this this lady at montgomery ward she
was african-american said to me you're
the most beautiful skin tone and lips
and my grandmother was like this daddy
that's why his friends are black and
he's dying he's already checking the
characteristics of blacks
she's the worst and she made me feel bad
because i got a compliment on my skin
and lips
and i thought
how can how can i feel bad that she gave
me a nice compliment that he was very
kind and my grandma was like pulling my
shirt come on let's go over here
where they don't compliment you
[Laughter]
awful man
bad things will happen if you feel good
about yourselves
well you know it's a common sense
building up self-confidence by by uh
building down self-confidence
it's a rough world out there you're not
gonna be [ __ ] your dad wasn't [ __ ] and
you're not gonna be [ __ ] i'll show you
and then he leaves he goes well get
ready for four years he's gonna come
back with a diploma because that's how
you get somebody that's how you inspire
somebody is to tell them that they can't
do it but george it's also a different
generation remember i mean
you know at least like your you know
your your daughter your you know it's
now the oprah dr phil generation where
people emote
right i don't even remember the word
emote i think i learned the word emote
like 10 years ago i i didn't know that
thing was a word a verb
uh and so you know it's a different
difference so you've seen crime go
i mean
anytime somebody disappears
for and they're not a celebrity or
anything they always look for
who would want this person to be gone
it's usually a love triangle
i remember the first uh workplace
shooting was like
you couldn't believe it that somebody
went in in san diego wherever and they
started shooting dude somebody going
postal there was there was a term and
then it just became
a thing that we
accepted that we accept everybody knows
people want to be copycats and it is a
generational gap so what makes you say
when to wake up one day and say okay you
know what i'm going to go get on a stage
and i'm going to try to make people
laugh
that that would that's that's well you
know i can't i mean in those in the 70s
i mean i saw guys that
i mean if you were
wanting to be a chef
right now these last 10 years would be
somewhere you'd go like this is the best
time to ever want to be a chef so you
had like johnny carson on you had
richard pryor was working george carlin
chichen chang
chico and the man sanford and son it was
like a bone a bonanza of great tv
comedies
and then if you look at johnny carson
you had jay leno on you had you know all
the all the guys robin williams
so to be inspired
was a great time to be inspired now if
you want to try and go and do it
now you have to go here
and
i just you know for being a disconnected
person like emotionally disconnected
it's like it's something that you can do
and not cry afterwards like i was awful
if you were awful you shrugged it off
you try to come back and i think that
what made me keep going back was that
i didn't feel anything like i didn't
feel that it was hurting me i thought oh
just keep going but are you one of these
guys who you know
like you see in sitcoms where those
comedians would have you have you ever
gotten heckled where you start getting
into it with the person heckling you
where it gets ugly uh i have but but
um
the more you learn the skill it's almost
like one one of the things that i
remember about
is they say
a police officer never gives up the gun
like he never gives the gun up
uh right because he's trying to lose
your power so
with us it's like you can't have
the audience have someone have the upper
hand on you have to remain
the upper hand and one night in in vegas
i was working in the at the maxim hotel
and i was the guy was talking and i was
kind of telling him to be quiet and then
somebody said why don't you just do your
act and not worry about who's talking
and the whole room clapped like against
me
and then the manager of the show called
me in my room and said hey man
you know that's just not supposed to
happen like you let the audience have
the upper hand
and you know you were talking to this
guy you were trying to get him to be
quiet meanwhile you were ignoring
everybody else and that guy said once
you shut up and just tell jokes and they
all started going crazy and you're like
okay i think i'd rather i mean if i
think if i wasn't in that position i'd
rather somebody heckle me than a silent
room
like a dead silent room
that's tough
yeah
and i lost the gig
tim allen was on tv in the in the maybe
early 90s and he left
and just this wave of people kind of
left with them and i was up next so
drama you're swimming upstream these
people are going up there you go up
there and you're following it's always
hard to follow a guy that's really good
and this guy from showtime ken weinstock
said let me just see how you work let me
do it for for blocking we were going to
do this two two parts of a showtime
special and i didn't get one lap you
could hear the [ __ ] plates in the
couch
not the catering [ __ ] hated the next
day he called me said hey man listen uh
you know last night it wasn't your best
you know and think we're gonna just kind
of go in a different direction so i lost
a gig early on when i think that money
was like 25 000.
and uh
i think it's a good lesson i think it
was a good lesson have you and you've
got to have lost
gigs in the last uh four years because
of taking political positions which i've
always told you is something i admire
greatly because there's you know there's
a lot of artists that chose to
instagram about their kids and their you
know making pasta and doing this and
that instead of
while our communities were getting
attacked and while our communities were
in distress and you you took a very
strong position and it was and it was
very very hard
but why'd you do that you know i just i
came up in a place where people
disrespected people by the color of
their skin and they were working hard
they used to say my grandfather
hiring him was like hiring two guys
and one guy because he worked so hard
and you know he didn't speak english
well and
he was a hard-working guy and to just
see people like when trump went out
there and called you know rapists and
criminals and i guess some are good
people
it's just like i can't i can't let that
happen i can't have this guy do that and
i knew him a little bit from my talk
show and stuff and he wasn't a bad guy
golf with them a couple times to [ __ ]
cheat her in golf
[ __ ] cheating
this [ __ ] listen listen i mean
this gentleman
he was hitting the ball so far right and
left that i'm like i tell the dude we're
playing with i go that can't be the same
[ __ ] ball
he goes how does he find it so he has a
caddy named rabbit so on the first so he
goes this is a this is my friend he had
a guy like an italian guy that was his
buddy pretty good golfer trump another
dude
this is rabbit why do you call him
rabbit [ __ ] trump hits it it goes
right that dude goes
i go oh that's why they call him rob i
found mr trump just like there's no way
that's the same thing but it went that
way so i try to start to look at it when
he tees it up i'm going like this like
you know and i think he knows so he's
turning it so that i can't read the name
because one guy stands and goes like
this i think he can see me
and he's hiding the name of the ball
and then i catch him putting and it was
another it was a callaway when he
started with like a titleist or
something
and he
i mean
it's like
that's why i don't play golf
you know i can't get the cheap i can't
get the ball through the windmill
golf taught me the the the
i mean you cheated you're only cheating
yourself that's why i cheated on other
people but and somehow in golf i don't
want to cheat myself but i learned
i mean respect and you know as a as a
person's hitting you're quiet when a
person's talking
you kind of give them the space to talk
so
um
[Music]
yeah i think it in life a little bit of
that stuff you know i always had decent
manners but
the integrity was lacking i think
in most of my life but
pretty easy now pretty casual now well
i i truly admire what you did because i
think you stood on principle when it's
easy not to and in an industry where it
has tangible
tangible costs and you know and by the
way you were so funny thank you
oh my god the the um
and uh uh the tangerine [ __ ]
the um
but um
it's the episode title i tried i tried
not to let the fact that others didn't
do it around like arouse me and get me
mad like i was just like you know what
whatever they're doing i don't care i
have i know who they all are i'm friends
with them
but that's them
but i i couldn't
i couldn't do it and that was not
make-believe you know in stand-up you
can create make-believe issues you know
my wife is this my kids are that it's
all make-believe but this was all very
real to me
because they're coming from where i came
from and just the fact that a guy who
had never really worked in his life who
had tried to get out of everything and i
remember when i said i didn't know you
were from england he's like england i
said you have a family crest
and he says and i quote oh i'm from
queens
if you change it 20
you can get away with it so i took the
british crest
and i added my own touches
and
i use it on my gates to everything and
honest golf shirts and things and then i
thought
later on i thought yeah perfect that's
somebody that would do that
that would create a family uh crest when
there isn't one so what would be on your
family crest if you were creating it
from scratch
there would be a beer that would be a
bed
a guitar and there would be a guitar
hell yeah
[Music]
and this summer i let myself go a little
bit but now that
you know we're going to some events now
and
hopefully you know
pandemic changes you know i've been
vaccinated so now it's time to take care
of my whales gill it's time to bundle up
with manscape performance package 4-0
inside the package
you'll find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold your goodies
you imagine watching tv and and knowing
that your balls smell good i don't know
if i would want to watch tv first of all
new performance package 4.0 includes the
new lawnmower 4.0 if you're looking to
cozy up this fall trimming is essential
the fourth generation trimmer features a
cutting edge ceramic blades to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced skin safe technology
it also gives you the ability to turn
the 4000k led spotlight on and off when
needed for a more precise shave plus
it's waterproof the performance package
for polio includes the weed whacker to
chop your worst weeds up
and top your nose and ear that's also
very important the nose in here trimmer
uses a 9 000 rpm motor powered 360
degree rotary dual blade system to
provide
proprietary skin
safe technology
which helps prevents nicks snags and
tugs in those delicate
holes
if i had a band i think i would name
them delicate holes
so seal the deal with manscape liquid
formulations the crop preserver ball
deodorant everyone knows pumpkin spice
lattes and ball deodorant go hand in
hand yeah then after receiving the
pumpkin patch and whacking the leaves
give your balls a boost and use the crop
reviver
manscaped even threw in two free gifts
to their performance package 4.0 the
manscaped boxers and the shed travel bag
get comfy on the home and on the go this
season
get 20 off free shipping with the code
omghi that's oh my god hi at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code omghi
manscape.com make your balls a priority
this fall choose manscape your balls
will thank you
they don't have to talk to thank you
you'll just know that they appreciate
everything that's going on they'll
breathe easy
[Music]
for all the people that i know in los
angeles and all the friends that i've
made out here
not one of them
cares enough about me to tell me the
things that that anna tells me oh you've
got great friends out here don't do it
but they don't but they don't you
you've got i mean you know out here they
leave you alone they don't they don't
really take an interest in your personal
life because out here just like hey
that's personal but okay you all live
too far away here
i know oh that's a thing too it takes so
long to go from you know
point a to point b yeah it does and you
don't know how long it will take because
you're just rolling the dice depending
on the time of day
you have great friends nothing's ever
the same twice either you know i'll tell
you what you have you have great male
friends
you don't have
uh as many you don't have you don't have
friends
i don't know
right
the uh they got bad enough
i mean eddie van halen was a great
friend to you arsenio is a great friend
here yeah i can think of all
of a bunch of friends
you know that it's interesting because
you know time yeah
you know times come and go like
if i
you know the the eddie van halen thing
was was
interesting because you know
it's like if there's a perfect
fit for two dudes like i got him to golf
and he loved golf and then i always
loved the guitar and he kind of gave me
a guitar and i had guitars and we would
talk guitarist but then you know he went
to the laker game we took him to pebble
beach and you know he would say you know
what's what's it like at pebble beach
and i go you want to go to pebble beach
let's go
and
he loved it and it just kind of was this
great
thing where not a
crossword ever spoken and just
all about love and friendship and
appreciation of somebody you miss him do
you find yourself thinking about him
yeah
because 65 and 60
too young i'd love to have another
10 15 years with the man yeah yeah is
that how old 65 when he passed 65.
and it was tough to see because you know
when it came back and you know i said
but are you gonna be all right and he's
like yeah yeah yeah this is that's not
much and
cancer you don't [ __ ] with cancer man
it's the war it's the worst it's the
worst thing it doesn't care who where
and or what
i just got notified today
a very dear friend of mine that i worked
with on the department
and i talked to him a few months ago
and checking up on him and he was sick
he was letting me know that they just
sent him home in the hospital they were
set up a hospital bed
he was telling me he was describing
hospice
oh wow and i said i'll check up on you
i said i'll be in touch with you i'll
check on you every week every other day
whatever
if you need anything let me know
he says no he says he says my daughter
will keep you in touch i've already
instructed my daughter to
talk to you and i said okay
so i didn't hear from the daughter so i
called him no response and i started
sending him text messages no response i
told my wife
i said i think he's passed
i think he's really sick
just got notified today i mean he sent a
letter his daughter sent a letter out
the smash list
announcing that he had passed
and he wanted everybody to know
how much he loved the department how
much he loved
and he wanted to reach out to his good
friend gil carrillo
and
it was special
and he was a good friend and and i
didn't know and that i knew then because
i told my wife i said
he he knows he's going and he just
doesn't he wants to literally go crazy
every week like i i i finally met
somebody
he cries more
don't go anywhere why because i'm a
detective no no because you cry
it makes me look like i'm the one in
charge listen man get your [ __ ] together
you know because uh and when you guys
were growing up what would every what
would every male figure
i cried today because they made a song
about that little someone
i was watching
it's that documentary and i don't cry
somebody said please don't tell me you
were watching my octopus teacher and
started crying over there
he was basically impossible
how much of that octopus was a [ __ ]
horror that not only is she the ocean
[ __ ] around but now she's out of the
ocean holding hands with a guy
he leaves and meanwhile
she's giving birth to a thousand [ __ ]
jellyfish and then
all [ __ ] beat up and then they eat
her up and spit her out the guy comes
looking for her and she's gone like a
[ __ ] horde with one heel right there
by the one shell by the rock bam what's
your name
it's a documentary it's just a crazy
[ __ ] yeah it's the craziest thing it's
like the guy
i think that loses his son or something
he goes in the water
i don't know how the guy has like like
develops a a relationship with his
octopus and goes and visits her every
single day
for
300 and they show up and they octopus
like
they're holding like an avatar when they
like connect ponytails yeah
[ __ ] thing and the guy's out there
and he misses he misses her but she's
like [ __ ] him i'm not going to be there
every time he comes into the water and
then she slides over and right and
she's
you're just like there's no way and the
dude's looking and you see the thing go
around her hand and you're like and
isn't that the craziest [ __ ] in the
world they're in love listen i i watch
the movie and then i'm like okay now you
know i'm gonna have this now this you
know this movie's gonna ruin octopus for
me you know
you know it's a very big thing in
spanish oh my god so i went and i
ordered the pulpo and i got sick i got
physically sick from eating
i like purple it's hard to cook
that was my lover
oh my goodness i mean it is the cr
you've never seen anything like because
you know
it's a tearjerker people go in the water
so this guy goes in there
george a lot of people go in the water i
just came back from hawaii a lot of
people go in the water did you have a
better time you don't like going in the
water the water
why does it does it mess up your hair
yeah you know the further you go into
the ocean the darker it gets
you know that you heard it here first
you're swimming around in water that
looks like where the all of the black
olives come in
black and you're just in there you're
like this is some black water
it is
freaky when you like can't see the
bottom it's terrifying and you're out
there we were out there in the boat
swimming in the water and it kind of got
away from me and then you start swimming
you go okay from that's from golf and
then my leg and i'm like oh hey i can't
i can't keep up with the boat
oh my god and then you're just a little
you know like a little last time like
the oyster so you put a little salt on
your fish because uh
and you're [ __ ] gone man
in the ocean you ain't [ __ ] i went on a
glass bottom uh catamaran when i was in
hawaii with a group of guys that i got
to play ball with over there
oh i was i was the only one drinking
tequila she finally just said here
here's a bottle you're the only drinking
it so i drank it and i told my buddies i
said hey gather the people around the
glass they want to see they want to see
fish i'm going to show my sea urchin
right now
and so i went off the side of the boat
my wife was on board the boat
everybody's over there by the sea i went
underneath one of the things pulled my
shorts on him
plastered my ass right up against him
and and the only one that got pissed off
was my wife
my wife was upset
because i had done that
how much tequila had you consumed by
that quite a bit you're throwing up that
cool
then i thought i was going to down
because i went the wrong way trying to
get back out holy [ __ ] just let me get
back to the middle okay take a breath
get your beard now go back out but you
know is there is there
is there one behavior we're looking for
like if someone says hey that's not
right that you do that that's not right
are we looking to be individuals or are
we looking for
our own behavior does that make it make
sense you know when someone says like
hey man you got a little bit loud last
night like but in the big picture what
does it [ __ ] matter man you don't
want friends to be judgmental you know
right yeah yeah
they can tell you things and they can
laugh about it but you don't want you
don't want judgmental okay so that's
what you have spouses for
his wife the only one who did not like
that amazing joke so yeah about the uh
your girlfriend in third grade
how are we talking did she listen to
that on the podcast
and you know what she said though she
said you know i really don't remember
getting that upset
and i said oh i do i
listen i really don't remember getting
that upset
is like listen [ __ ] let's move
on to something else
i was in the uh uh don't make me put
this behind you there was this girl that
i went to school with sharp and i became
friends her two brothers and i we all
grew up together in the third grade
before i knew her two older brothers
they were twins
first girl i ever kissed was her it was
in the third grade a sweet innocent kiss
but i never and so we went through high
school she was never my girlfriend never
kissed her again we're friends
period just a few months ago i go to a
funeral
and then we go get something to eat and
a bunch of people from the funeral a
bunch of high school friends were going
to the same place went out there and
there she was
eat and i said hey you know i still
remember that first kiss third grade
you messed up you never should have said
that and my wife got upset oh yeah so
it's weird
for the kids
remember that car i haven't had i
haven't seen that car in 40 years you
still have the same lips that kiss the
cochino universe like that
possibly this was in front of your wife
that you remember a kiss from you know
just remember but it wasn't
it it wasn't and then now it's going to
come up for the next 60 years you won't
even be around this will be coming up
you know i had i had a boyfriend i had
an ex-boyfriend who would say that every
time i got hysterical i'd get historical
i've heard that in like like alcoholics
anonymous sort of recovery or something
like i've heard it in that tradition
like yeah what's hysterical so we talked
about this it's true that's where they
go there you have got to stop talking
about this we're trying to help you by
changing the subject we talked about it
on the show
and we were listening to it and she was
she was listening to it
and she said
i don't remember getting that upset i
said oh i do and but she wasn't upset
that was the move on her that was like
this is now going back home and your
granddaughter and your wife are going to
be pissed oh never in any time i've ever
gotten angry do i ever use profanities
yeah because somebody told me when i was
a kid
so you say something nasty you can't
take it back it's done so i i
i don't use any profanities well you
know in the script that mine and i have
at nbc that they have me calling her the
b word and uh nbc was like well you know
it's a hard one to come back from and
i've never called her that like i've
never really disrespected mine ever
yeah i hit her once
when she was like three because she was
chasing anna in the car
and i didn't like it i didn't hear her
heart but i didn't like i didn't like
the way it felt yeah
you know i spanked her and i just only
once i didn't i didn't
people that abused kids and listen i was
a kid that i don't think i was hit i
think more mental but i didn't like it
and i and i remember having friends that
would get beaten by their parents
and i just
never thought about what it was like my
mom was a tough one in my family
my mom she was she she wouldn't hesitate
did she was she a chancla thrower she
was a chancla thrower of the archaeas i
mean
doesn't matter what i want that to be an
uh an olympic sport do you know what's
talking about there's some new sports
channel throwing should be an olympics
no one's going to watch the [ __ ]
olympics then let's create some [ __ ]
news
there's a lady that there's a kid
running in the alley and the lady comes
i don't ask that she reaches out throws
it hits the kid in the head the kid's 50
feet away mom takes it out
frappe and you can see it going and the
kid hits him in the hand and the crowd
goes wild
remind me i mean what are the chanclas
also i mean like your mom's chancellor
aren't they also like boomerangs because
i don't remember my mother walking with
one chancellor to go pick up the
character she picked it so i think that
[ __ ] came back right to her foot no my
mom would throw two of them
she won one cup of one
in the morning my grandma threw a butter
knife at me and i went like that
and
at school later on somebody said what do
you have on your shirt i had butter on
my hand i didn't feel with my i didn't
feel it hit me because i went like that
and then i was in class and there was a
kid behind me he goes what's going on
she's got some lando likes i was a
master of ceremonies at my mother's
retirement from beverly hospital there
were doctors nurses she'd been a
housekeeper for over 33 years your mom
worked there my mom worked there and so
i was emc at her retirement
bunch of people there and i said for
those who don't know me
i'm so corrupt i'm the son of socorro
you all know her as korra
i said as for myself
i said i'll tell you my name is gil
carrillo but for the first 18 years of
my life i went through an identity
crisis because i thought my first name
was cabron
and that's how she gobbled on you know
and
and my mom wanted to die because i was
using that kind of language in front of
doctors and everybody else
and no really she said oh she's oh yeah
she's pissed
oh she was upset finished telling us you
never use profanity
i don't i don't know when you're saying
that
type five he does when i'm angry or
upset you only use it when you're happy
oh yeah
i cussed like a sailor you know
you know what i think you're a candidate
to go down to marina del rey try to fall
in love with a [ __ ] squid down there
[Laughter]
no hey i couldn't get away with kissing
kissing in third grade i can do any good
with the squad with the underwater love
of america i have to help you so much
you've got to stop talking about this
you remember who your first kiss was but
you know but you know listen
you know i love al like like her husband
was he's in that what was the 302 votes
what's it called
oh there were the rocket documentary 374
like i i didn't there's a great
documentary about about uh florida
racism
because i was in santa monica and al
gore was president and then i got home
and and george bush was present what the
[ __ ] happened
uh because i was in the car just kind of
you're like how long was i out i
remember i was in an audition they go
hey we got a new president
and my husband was was the chair of the
republican party of florida when that
happened jeb bush was governor i mean it
was a man they did a move man but
they didn't move oh they did a movement
he was on there and he was so articulate
and so like such
in control i said man that's that's
that's your guy right she goes yeah i
said i didn't know i watched that thing
five times because i'm a
yeah that makes me astute political guy
but i'm not really into the politics but
i like the stuff that shines like a guy
that you hadn't seen before
shine and then alex pinellas the other
guy disappear
and then him saying if janet reno wants
to come down here i'd like for her to
come down here and she goes down there
and she says you you were talking about
what'd you say about me right right alex
and she and she disappeared and they
said if you if you want to go and get um
what's the guy's name that little kid
elian elian gonzalez come and get him oh
yeah
and they came and got him yeah he did
and that's when they opened the closet
door and the guy had the gun and he's
holding the thing and you're just like
whoa and it probably cost al gore i mean
amongst a bunch of other things
but certainly
the uh you know the cubans would say
come november we will remember and they
did they did man but part of why what
makes cuban americans so politically
powerful they you know they remember man
they remember and they come out we don't
have that we don't have that here but
but staying on that topic they do
remember and you know what was funny i
mean it's not funny but when their
family ran out of establish they were
fainting in the yard and fading over a
chair they were throwing chairs and in
that street that's not a big street all
the houses are closed it was ground zero
for for at that time smoke in the air
lights they came in
and came out right and they were gone
racing and it was crazy crazy man that
they went and did that it was like they
went in there and did like a military
and it had become like a like a like
like a shrine don't you remember you
know all sorts of political figures and
uh
folks would come and visit the house
with a little kid and bring a dog and
bring this and bring that and it was a
constant vigil in front of of the house
and i think um
i think it was probably the first time
in since you know since they had gotten
here where cuban americans really
suffered you know a a blow a big blow
to their political power they you know
they i mean they were aghast that bill
clinton had given the order
of sending the little boy back the
little boy had become
so symbolic do you remember that i was
going to say yes remember listeners who
are unaware did someone want to like
just sort of briefly encapsulate the
situation that we're talking about
because i imagine like i mean i would
not be the person to do it i barely i
was very young when this happened but i
can imagine a lot of our audience was
like not born without a computer in
front of you
okay so let's say let's give it a
nutshell okay elian gonzalez was a
little boy who ha who was found floating
in a raft his mom had
had tried to bring him out of cuba
the the mom died coming to america on
the raft and the little boy was found he
must have been four or five years old at
the time was found floating in his raft
and he got rescued by the coast guard
brought to miami where he was reunited
with family that he'd never met their
cousins and uncles and things and then
the father who had been left in cuba who
was still in cuba started demanding that
the child be returned to him to the
father in cuba and the cuban-american
community
refused to send the kid back to the
final situation yeah so it became it
became much more
than just about the child it became a
fight against communist cuba
and you know freedom in exile it was it
was symbolic to a
huge uh historical and to be cuban at
that time in miami was everything that
anybody talked about i mean you know and
i didn't i just read uh within the last
year where he's now he's now an adult
and very happy that he's in cuba well
he's gotten all sorts of of uh he's
gotten all sorts of special treatment
right i mean they treat him as the
symbolism he's like donald trump you're
right
you know he's so they so i mean
assuming he's very happy in cuba
assuming he's saying uh the truth he
hasn't had the typical uh cuban life
cuban life as you know as somebody
that's not
a famous
figure with symbolic with political
symbolism
and and the family that he had in miami
did they just
if they disappeared they didn't well the
the the the cousin opened up a salon a
hair salon marie lacy say yamaha on you
know on eighth street but look you know
things in cuba are really rough and then
the last we saw
what i saw this year i had never seen
and i'm not cuban american i'm married
to a cuban american but i've lived in
miami for over 40 years
and so i've you know i'm very close to
seeing what that community has gone
through and july 11 of this year
all over cuba it was like you know like
a brush fire protests for freedom uh
erupted in a place where there's
draconian
backlash from the government so they you
know they know they're risking their
lives and as we speak here there's
hundreds we don't even know the number
but hundreds and hundreds of cubans that
have been put in jail beaten that have
disappeared and that we know uh nothing
about who had taken to
to the streets so they i mean they shut
that thing down took out the internet
because it's the first thing they do
right right they don't want the eyes of
the world the cuban government or any
any repressive government they don't
want the eyes of the world seeing what
they're doing so it has gone away and it
hasn't gone away because it's not an
issue anymore it's gone away because
every community way of communicating in
cuba has been eliminated yeah it's been
it's i mean
it wasn't it wasn't too good to begin
with right the internet service and you
know all of that just imagine a few
years maybe five seven years ago guys i
mean cedric went to cuba people were
going to cuba and they were going oh
it's great you got to go you got to go
do this they brought a bottle of rum and
you're like this is the most amazing rum
i've ever had they have amazing things
over there that
i mean it's
it's cuba like that that that
but you know i had a lot of friends that
went to cuba when obama changed the
travel have you been no i can't go
the uh
but the um
they went with the travel like there was
a time when every time i got on and i
live in miami yeah so every time i got
on a plane from miami or to miami there
was some sort of you know guy in a
hawaiian shirt that was on his way to
cuba on his way back from cuba and um
all my friends wanted to go to cuba so
they'd go to cuba for the first time
and then it would be like well are you
going back no the wi-fi sucks there's no
water pressure the rooms are moldy the
air conditioning doesn't work you know
because american tourists are right
yeah we want you know we want reliable
wi-fi and we want good water pressure in
the shower head and we want yeah and so
yeah when i went to hawaii there was a
gecko in the hotel room and anne's like
we got to change rooms
i said wait a minute
this is a little gecko we're in hawaii
let me get him out of the room and then
we'll close the door and then he'll be
gone but it'll change rooms because
there's a gecko
i used to take a shower in the morning
and there would be geckos on the the
shower had a glass you know of course
and they would be geckos on the on the
outside it was beautiful to see them
there on the on the thing in the morning
we take a shower listen i could live
with a gecko i couldn't live with like a
snake or anyone or a you know there's no
snakes in the water right right here in
east like where i used to where you go
eating at dirt and dead man you go and
see cool on the wall just keep just keep
your feet moving they don't bother you
just you
learn
how do people have those those those
iguanas as pets no see they're over
there in in florida
like they're just loose they're no
ownership
they're obviously not central americans
central america is considered a delicacy
in a an
aphrodisiac the meat of iwana
we were in the hotel they say it tastes
like chicken every time somebody says
something tastes like they smell like
chicken why don't you just eat chicken
this is how bad it was when i got
divorced i said mira if dick tastes like
chicken i'm going in that direction
that's how bad and then i had a promoter
that was uh that was gay and he came out
of the office he goes what did he say
tell me about the different colors here
what's the okay so i'm not a beer
drinker but somebody just tell me about
this this one is
and that is uh
that is like the 50 50 bar the orange uh
the orange ice cream with the cream in
it we're talking about the george lopez
brewing company beers
beers
infused cream ale
so this is beer
creamy ale and beer
okay what's it called
you know this is uh this is hibiscus so
hibiscus
so of course that's great that's one of
my favorite sour beers so so of course
over there at the restaurant somebody
put ice with this and tequila and they
made themselves their own little drink
oh that's interesting we call it the
octopus
[Laughter]
if i went to the ocean an octopus came
and held my hand i think i'd only have
one date like it wouldn't come back
it's not you it's me getting involved
with that with that guy so when you
lived in hawaii did you snorkel or scuba
when you spent when you would spend a
lot of time there
um
we'd go to the bay manali bay right
there and i would go in there you know
when i was 15 my uncle lived in coronado
in san diego and a kid came out and he
had a jellyfish on his side
and he had gotten bit by a jellyfish and
he had this huge red thing and yeah you
know
so the rest of my life from 15 the rest
of my life i never wanted to get bit by
a jellyfish you know just like it and
and you know never going in the water i
think the odds were pretty good that i
wasn't i wasn't then we moved to hawaii
and i go in there and one late afternoon
i get out and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
and i'm looking at oh it's all red right
here and i got and i've gotten bit by a
jellyfish but what is that guy who
doesn't like swimming in the ocean dude
moving to hawaii you call for gold
for golf you know
it's um that's a good question i mean i
went over there you know i i i bought
the trip the first trip
from mayan school like uh uh auction at
auction so so uh um what was his name
together on the uh the little the man
um david murdock uh mr murdoch so
murdoch rich guy
on the island
gave uh
a woman from the school a trip for like
four days and we bought it i went over
there i was doing my show and i was
touring all that stuff and i went over
there and in three days i came back and
i was like hey i feel
recharged i feel really great and then
we went to a look at some places we
bought a place it wasn't that much we
bought a place
and then i started to go on hiatuses and
in the summer ann would go and mine
would go and we'd all go together and it
just became something that i just kind
of felt really comfortable over there
that's my favorite spot in the whole
world that i've been to that i i love it
i was offered a job over there with
pleasant hawaiian tourists i say you'd
make a good tour guide and we have
spanish-speaking tours coming over here
at least three times a week
and i i have fun i i loved it
uh you know what i'm doing
well i i didn't want to do it then and
and now
i don't want to move over there i'm
happy where i'm at oh you're the only
one not moving over there i know you
know
everybody's moving to florida to hawaii
people are buying houses sight unseen
yeah sight unseen
i went over and played when i first went
and uh i saw a guy look to wine big guy
hair long and i said uh hey so you know
so how long you what island were you
born on he goes i'm from mr lake i was
born in el monte and i said what oh you
look like you're hawaiian he goes i've
been here so long i look like he looked
like he was a wine he was a chicano dude
and he went over there to go do some
work
and then he had gotten a divorce and he
said [ __ ] it i'm going to stay here i'm
not going to go back why should i go
back i got nothing over there yeah and
he he's been there forever he was happy
he looked great
there's another lifestyle you really
like it
so you're you're
i would say you know your revolution of
your life is hot you know you go to new
york and you do the view you're on cnn
you're you're always in the
in the midst of what's really going on
around people who are pro and against
like you
you've been in combat in the news
so
to go over there is so counter to what
you've been but in watching your
instagram and seeing the things i know
you know i've never seen no we haven't
known each other that long but i love to
see
those pictures of you like that like
oh yeah i have so happy and then you and
al dancing and then him having fun him
going in the in the tube in the old
sugar cane we had a we had a blast but i
you know i think part of it
is the pandemic right where we've all
been locked up for so long and haven't
you know had human interaction having i
mean so just remember my husband had
coveted right right and so i mean he was
in the hospital so so the idea that
you know look i know we're not past it i
know we're in the midst of another surge
with a delta variant but you know we've
got vaccines man we got we got ways to
treat it that we didn't
uh a year ago right and we should be
very grateful how did you know that el
how did you know how did he know did you
know how he got it or or how it happened
uh i think he got it from
i think he got it from you know our
housekeeper so our one housekeeper got
it and then we know somebody else that
got it from their housekeeper as well
right
i thought you were talking about
arnold's arnold schwarzenegger got it
from his housekeeper yeah
but he he
so we both want to get tested
and uh
you know i come i i i i was you know you
have to link on this thing and open it
up and i see the test results for me is
negative but i was in the studio because
i was doing the view that day and when i
you know oh you saw him and i tell him
hey
uh i tested negative says and he
couldn't figure out how to open the link
he was at home and when i got home like
at one in the afternoon he was asleep
i'm like [ __ ] this i don't like this
this and so i i looked at his link and
it said
he had it i never got it
nice and what did he have to do then
when you told me i got it dude well he
says it was like the worst moment in his
life
[Laughter]
so um yeah but it was you know it was
the the scariest part about covet is
gauging when you can't handle it at home
and and trying not to miss that window
because the treatments work very are
very effective if you hit it within a
certain window right you know if you
wait too long
so you know you've got a well you know
we talked about a spike leading last
night and then the guy who lost his
mother and she was in a nursing home and
he said well i want my mom to go to the
emergency and they said well no they
won't you know she'll it should be worse
but in reality
more people had it in there
and she stayed in there and she didn't
have a chance when she
finally went to emergency like the guy
said you should have brought her to
emergency like five days ago and
you know the the nursing home said no
she'll be fine here you're gonna take
her to the emergency emergency she'll be
worse over there but
it wasn't
and that's tough because that's a
that's a
it's a life and death thing it's not
yeah you're going to get better we lost
a lot of people
hawaii is a paradise yeah that's what it
is you know i remember coming back from
hawaii on one trip they said
welcome back to reality and that was
that was it it really does change you i
mean i mean um you liked it well part of
it is you know
i mean it's
six hours behind the east coast so you
wake up in hawaii
and you know half the bad [ __ ] that's
going to happen in the day is already
done
and you're having a hard time turning on
the news and seeing all the
stuff that's happening in the world
because you're you know you're looking
at geckos and hibiscus flowers so just
you know it's you you've kind of
just i think just the distance
makes you disconnect i think that i
think it's hard for to keep up with
what's happening in the east coast from
here it's true
even from here
right you know i went over there you
know i was going with cheeto we were
going to the big island and anthony and
those guys were going to be out there
cedric and then i said they you know
they wanted me to go do jimmy fallon so
you're in jimmy fallon you're in a suit
you come out you talk jimmy fallon you
go you get on a plane and you know in
whatever half a day or a day you're
sitting with those guys having drinks
and and watching baseball in hawaii and
golfing barefooted and you're like man
yesterday i was in new york
well i was in the suit with jimmy fallon
and here i'm barefooted with these guys
golfing
in another world your problems are gone
and just before you walked in today i
was telling grant
that
that's the way i feel all the problems
in the world no matter what my problems
are
when i come here they're gone
because we're just having fun you know
interacting here i didn't expect to make
a friend like guild this year because
you know when when the night stalker
documentary came out you know first i'm
fascinated by by crime you know charles
brown is a fan of mine
on the record on the record fan you love
like the most eccentric stuff yes
so inna was like have you seen it yet
and you know when i watched it again i
watched it five times you know and i see
him and i know frank salerno because he
helped me with something like 10 years
ago and i call him and he answers the
phone you know when somebody's really
into like law and somebody's a lawyer or
somebody somebody you can count on you
can count him at you can call him at any
time in the answer anytime you call me i
don't answer i look you know when i you
you know and he's like hello it's like
frank it's jordan hey what's up george
it's talked to gil ah occasionally you
think he might give my information sure
give it to he gave it to him
and then you know he comes over here and
we start talking and it's like that
so i haven't seen a documentary what
what what's what did you
it is a no i know who the night stalker
is but what did you what was your role
in the whole thing also i was co-lead
investigator on the case he held a
ladder wow so the whole dock the whole
documentary is about
it's not looking at it from the
killer side not the serial killer it's
looking at from the investigative side
everything that the community
investigators went through so it's about
myself my partner
my wife is on it what uh
she did not want to do it i had to
explain to her nobody's going to force
you to do anything you don't want to do
you're not going to do it but
look how much
help you could give other wives of other
cops
that are out there that will see what
you went through to be married to a cop
during this time so they did
and it went uh then he has a back story
of you know being in vietnam and then
going to um
you know training and becoming a sheriff
and his father with his father in there
and then you know being plucked from
being a patrol cop to wanting to be
where can i watch this
netflix netflix and it's called the
nightstalker night stalker hunt for
cereal so let me ask you this as a
former you know as a vet yes and as a
former cop yes when you saw the things
that happened uh at the capitol in
washington in january 6 what what went
through your mind
the fact that
the cops just and i only know what the
public scene and what i see as a cop
that
they were very very undermanned
nobody had any intelligence there the
cops were left out to drive by
themselves they should have had more
people there it it's just to follow the
whole system those cops had no way to go
yeah yeah i mean yeah but would they not
be there because the capital doesn't
require that many officers or i have no
idea what they require what their system
is like i think he's right look we knew
for you know for days they had been
saying for weeks they had been saying
we're going to go to the capitol on
january 6 we're going to stop this it
was a whole thing you know it was a
whole it was a i mean it didn't just
happen in a vacuum all of a sudden in
one day it was
weeks and weeks there's intelligence
that comes in for stuff like that we
have it here they already find like what
airline to take or they all play on the
scene you know so it was just
a breakdown
somebody
did not want that
to happen didn't want the cops to be
prepared they wanted
uh this to go on
you know and i don't know who how what
or why because i'm not involved with any
information is it the boy annabelle
jared kushner the little monitor
i don't know you know what somebody made
a little meme of a doll and they put his
face on it on a couch sitting by itself
it was eerie as [ __ ]
like yorona and annabelle i don't know
the little jared doll if i put that one
out why not people would be they would
be throwing flowers like please don't
kill any of my family members
i'll tell you what the poor cops what
they had to testify yeah when i was
looking at part of their testimony
uh i just
they're weak you know they they're
untrained they're not good they
you know
no they weren't prepared i mean they
were devastated by the are they coming
someone committed suicide
yeah and they have the
they didn't use the capital players or
cops that testified were weak yeah oh
gosh i don't know i i can't i i really
don't know
from a different perspective but i i i
thought they
what we saw them endure what we saw on
video the beatings that they took the
attacks that they took were
were brutal sure that they survived and
they stayed out there and they and
frankly they've you know
for them speaking out for them has you
know has had political consequences
yesterday i was reading about a guy
who's been in hiding for
yeah that's the guy that's the guy that
the police that's a guy that shot the
lady that you know he's been hiding
because he had death threats and
everything else they when i say they're
weak i i thought
just from a personal perspective my
opinion my opinion only please don't
hate me if you do so what
uh i'm
somebody was after money
they're reading their statements
this is how bad it really really was
having been
in law enforcement having been shot at
by cops
when i was wearing a ray jacket
everybody in a congressional hearing
reads their statement because you sure
it wasn't your granddaughter because
you've got to submit your statement
with your granddaughter now under my own
mark carr chick
what about the guy that told mitt romney
this way
eugene
yeah gene levy
no no not different eugene okay
i gotta look it up
he saved his life yes he did that but
you know what it was it was officer
eugene if they would have thought they
would have gotten anybody mike pence or
or nancy pelosi or any legislator any
they would have killed that person man
sure you know that right
it would have been something that you
had at that moment yeah oh my god i mean
that was hard enough but
to see them up there hiding and and and
i mean anybody would hide
but they were out for
sure if they had if they had caught
someone i don't know if it's a lack of
training what kind of orders they were
given to begin with
uh the guy that acted right
i shouldn't say it a guy that reacted to
the condition the situation was in
was the man that just came out and
started talking he fired his gun this is
why i did it she's dead
you know and and i don't mean that you
go out and start shooting everybody not
at all
but
he did what he thought was right you had
to protect the castle and and so
uh the other guys i don't know if it's
because of a lack of training because of
the lack of
what their leadership was telling them
to do uh i just didn't buy it all right
how big is it how about eugene goodman
by the way so usually they were making
it up
no i don't think they're making i i
think they were
getting i think i think they were i'm
out
i've been outnumbered i've been attacked
and i know
but i think that somebody
saw i
i'd be shocked if each one of them
didn't have an attorney
of course they need to have an attorney
and their attorney said okay this is
what we got to say this is what we got
to do because they're looking at money
on the ins on the inside so i think
they didn't lie i think maybe it was
embellished as to their own personal
feelings
and that's just a personal opinion from
having been
on both sides of the fence
do you think that
i think it was
i think it was an incredibly traumatic
experience for them and i think for
america frankly i think many people you
know and i think that's why you've seen
the number of suicide rates that we've
seen in the capitol police because it
was demoralizing but you know i say this
not you know i don't have the the
experience you have as a former cop for
me
as for me as somebody who fled
political uh
violence as somebody who fled communism
to see that i just you know i've always
put this country in a pedestal where i
think these things don't happen
in america you know they happen in cuba
they happen in venezuela they happen in
nicaragua but they don't you know they
happen in afghanistan they don't happen
in america to see that kind of violation
of democracy of our biggest symbols of
democracy
was was heartbreaking the reality is
nothing has ever happened like that
historically
in the capital nothing
so how prepared were they
you have to train cops how prepared were
they if they never thought this was
going to go on and i know this because
i've traveled the united states
training other cops
on
different issues but when you go when
you leave
california
or leave southern california you find
out that some of these midwestern
northwestern states
and
all the way over to these except for the
all the way to the east coast they don't
get formalized training you know they
don't get that so they're not educated
so now all of a sudden you're putting
people out there that are untrained
don't know and now they're reacting on
their own
if they're not prepared it leads to
problems you know when i was doing
stand-up uh when ronald reagan got shot
and he was out there
and waving and you know james brady got
hit
i was there the next week and they were
creating a barrier where the car would
go in and the gate would with a gate
would go down
and he could go in where before you had
to walk from the curb to
the street and they had to eliminate
that because that had just happened i
mean he was right there in the wide open
and hinckley was as close as the secret
service were yeah and then that changed
and then
if you look at you know bobby kennedy at
the ambassador and then when i went to
the inauguration of obama and at some
point nobody could go past this area and
all the phone service was cut out and
nobody they had their little pins and
you know i was i was hosting the
military thing but
i couldn't go past here and and that all
was was private and you know that the as
soon as you look at your phone and you
had no bars that he was closer and then
when he left there's no bars and you
look and then now you have communication
but they do is a great job for him the
president now even even that's the same
service secret service because that's
the president
the guards i i'd be
i'd be very interested just
personally not that it makes a
difference
if they are
underpaid yeah you know if they're not
paid enough commensurate to other
departments around there
and you know you can tell us
if they have an iron on badge instead of
a real one there you go
you know that's it you know when you get
a windbreaker and they go well well
congratulations yeah yeah yeah they're
uniform and it's a you know they it's
the higher security of the office eugene
goodman
if you if you hire security security
should be security it should they should
be prepared for something to happen at a
bank
at a at a drug store wherever people go
and if they had the intelligence that
they
should have had
there should have been more people there
and it shouldn't have gone above their
pay grade oh it is above their price
that's the decision that the four
officers oh no no i totally agree with
you they you know they were dealt the
hand they were dealt sure and what about
the president saying and i'm gonna walk
down there with you
a lot of steps down there they're great
steps they're beautiful sticks
there's a lot of stiffness
and uh and he then he bails out i think
he's chicano
obviously he's not orange he's really
light brown no
he he said i'm going and then they're
like nah he's just remember his bones
not chicano he's not no but he incited
he if you you know behind that glass
uh civil discord
all i know the name of my next special
by the way i i i really don't know what
i learned
a long time ago is the american people
only know what they want us to know
and and and i you know from being
there's a lot of things
helicopter parts you know because i flew
what was then classified across enemy
lines into laos and cambodia
and aircraft going down and then all of
a sudden
the cambodians are showing
on the press hey here's a piece of tail
tail rotor here's a helicopter number
and the united states is categorically
denying it saying hey they could be
anywhere in the jungles of vietnam that
doesn't prove us anything when in
reality i knew we were going across
and so they only want you to know you
only know what whatever they want us to
know
and so i
i i i don't know but i'm very happy
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on right now
and yeah in the world george do you miss
uh you were you know you were just doing
a little comedy but do you miss tori
um
you know after 14 you know after 14
months i went out there or longer than
14 months and i was really off on i've
never really been awful people think i'm
awful but that's their opinion it's not
the performance was awful but
i
was rusty and bad and couldn't think and
couldn't put the sequence together in
the beginning and then to get it back up
again in the summer like a couple months
later i liked it i like i think i'm
better than i was because i took a
mental break away but then going back
it's i felt i was better i did really
like it and i missed it where i thought
i didn't because of you know because you
have success you think that
the thing that got you there so it's not
like riding a bike it's not like right i
thought you gotta you have to work on it
that's what he told me he said it was i
thought it was like riding a bike and it
wasn't you just come back from portland
oregon
i then i'll read you a joke that i wrote
went to go see him do you write your own
jokes oh yeah
then i went to go see somebody else
takes them and then i get credit for
they call me a thief
and when i went to see him right after
that
he killed it
i did have yes you did
um
the they go they have their crew to
smile no i don't we never accept
compliments with my grandma my
girlfriend will go george has the kids
dude
it's come setting it up oh you're
setting it up okay
all right so um wait a minute i got a
lot of i think there might be something
you're feeling rusty now i'm rusty right
now
[Laughter]
these kids in there tic-tac
what is the kids with the tick-tock i
don't even know i get tick-tock [ __ ]
about me now
dancing with richard who cares
yeah maybe dancing with a nightstalker
yeah
yeah i mean that's just funny
all right
i just deleted it are you gonna tell me
the joke no no i'm changing the subject
because i can't read and talk at the
same time
the uh but you know the the uh
the nights at that time in the 80s
um
i worked in northridge he struck in
northridge and before the internet
before you would read about it the next
day the news was at five
and eleven there was a 24 hour news
cycle and even that you knew he was out
there
and he still struck and as things were
as it started to get dark
people were everybody was going home
and the guy still
um
was out there
looking for doors that were open and
killing people right
yeah
how many people did he kill we had 14
here
we looked at about eight more but there
wasn't sufficient evidence to make it
part of
uh we didn't want to lose anything and
he said in the end he said he was good
for
four more
that we didn't know about and give him
about seven years in custody he'd be
willing to talk to me about it
that never happened but we looked at
eight there just wasn't enough evidence
did he die yeah he died june 7 2013. and
when he died people got mad because they
they thought he didn't serve enough time
in prison but he died hey he's dead who
cares yeah they were like
enough time i just know that we won the
appeal
i was just watching i was watching a
documentary the day on netflix it's
called cocaine cowboys and it's about
the 80s in miami when there was you know
these uh
uh you know the drug running there
wasn't
no but i've been wanting to watch it's
amazing
and the so one of the one of the folks
involved in the in the drug running
uh
became a fugitive the dude was a
fugitive they were looking for him for
25 years disappeared and you know where
he was
orlando
like hiding in plain sight
he lived in orlando with his wife for 25
years the brother of uh yes
yeah willie falcone and he disappeared
he was in orlando for 25 years
you know
did they catch him uh yeah they didn't
catch him yeah like 25 years later is
that guy salma good is he in stone
prison or yeah he's in in the maximum
security prison place in in colorado i
think he's like next to the unit bomber
and child chapel he put him in the place
job oh i think the chapel's there too
right they haven't moved him over there
you know how bad that place is in new
york that metropolitan were right
epstein's el chapo have seen one it was
uh
um el chapo where he came in humane it
was inhumane el chapo was like this is
the worst place i've ever been no but
that place in colorado is rough that i
think it's called adx or something yeah
the supermax like you never see anybody
else i think it's all honest i think you
barely see sunlight i think there's a
little window uh and they put some of
the rough rough guys that's where that
guy francisco duran who can get his
couple you want to go over there that
francisco duran the guy that ran across
the white house with a long coat and was
shooting
the white house didn't hit anything he
made the white house and he was running
across that's when they blocked off the
street to the weather they used to be
able to drive in front so he's running
like that and he was in a long trench
coat that was in the mid 80s and he's in
there
and uh
you know you don't hear him i don't hear
about him but
it would be
like the love boat of criminals if you
if you guys think his wife where is
chapel's wife at
which one
i don't think i don't think they got
they didn't put her in i thought they
just got out yeah they arrested her
recently
recently yeah i read where does all that
money go
like if
pablo escobar had billions of dollars
and he spent a million dollars in rubber
bands like they said every year i mean
he was making
that much money
where does all that cash go i have no
idea disintegrates i think if they
they're trying to bury it or don't you
remember that that they they they buried
it and
it rained and they got moldy and
i who knew money could rot you know yeah
it's a good problem to find out and the
guys would say like it you can't do
anything with it because it's so much
you can't carry it
and you can't
really kind of hide it it's so heavy
they put it in walls they were put in
the walls and it would disintegrate
and yeah all over the
that's before place
yeah now she's on bitcoin right crazy
man
like all that bitcoin stuff and the nfts
where they spend millions of dollars
what did i just see are you not making
some nfts yeah
you know you know for the longest time i
thought that meant no [ __ ] tacos
hey that said that
how about mft more [ __ ] more [ __ ]
tacos you said that also so did you sell
the nfts
i sold all the wrestling masks yeah
here's my daughter i want to do this
with you of course it's not something
like you know hey let's do this together
uh father
water if you're not daughter to hit it
there because she's fine we're having
fun
so what do i do just aim for the pond
what is that
that's family guy
i don't find this one funny some of them
are funny
we're having fun
okay mine you just got put on blast send
better tick tocks that wasn't like a
girl
you could literally burp her over your
shoulders
i don't i can't date any young well
not that i can't neither can i
oh i can't
you're not married are you no no no you
live with your girlfriend uh no
single what's your age range because we
need to find you a girl you're all dead
listen
here's the problem i have you go out you
have a wonderful evening you have dinner
and when you hug them goodbye they pee
you know like clintus would set up
taking the rest of the way alone
uh yeah
when you fly back nothing worse than
meows
you kind of like this i like you over
here i like it over here too i'm going
to carlos viva's uh tonight at the
hollywood bowl
it's friday night yeah yeah but you know
what i want to go to hawaii when you're
in hawaii let's go mama i gotta i gotta
i gotta have an excuse to come when i
live when i live and then go from here
because from miami it's like no no no no
stay here a couple times
a little bit when i lived in hawaii
i would go
barefooted to the store and swim trunks
and a t-shirt
and then go i mean it's just a way to
live no it isn't real
in brazil no yes people are like in in
bikinis in the bank and i
mean you know an old t-shirt inside out
yeah everything's laid back trunks and
you're walking barefooted to the aisle
and you know
yeah
and then and then you know [ __ ]
disappeared like you have to and you
have to know when the shipment of comes
in from
the mainland or wherever you get the
meat so that you get it the first two
days because if not toward the end of
the month there's you go to the market
there's nothing there yeah
because because people buy it remember
you're on an island so this this island
i was at kauai
there's like chickens all over the place
these chickens there's chickens all over
but i'm talking thousands of chickens
everywhere george and i'm thinking these
chickens gotta taste real bad that
nobody's killing these chickens and
eating each other they gotta be tough as
hell they taste like something breed of
chicken
they're the only ones it's like chicken
they're the only ones that don't taste
like chicken
no fail you know what because when you
get away from the colonel and kfc and
for local they go listen hey
you feel no threat over here you can you
can do whatever you want
in uh remember hawaii used to be
pineapples so when we went to move to
hawaii the guy would say you see that
little plat there's a little black
stuff in the like plastic
they started to cover the pineapples
with plastic right
but plastic doesn't disintegrate
so they would cover them for the heat to
help the pineapples grow and when they
picked the pineapples they roto-tilled
the plastic back into the ground and
they would kill the roots of the
pineapple uh and they couldn't get it
they couldn't get it all out so if you
drive by the side of the road you'll see
little black things coming out of the
ground and it's it's the plastic it
hasn't disintegrated but they're still
growing pineapples right no
i moved to like the philippines and to
other places
and they used to grow sugar and they
don't do that anymore
a bunch of couples and a bunch of people
went on this hawaiian trip
and a couple friend of ours just one of
the wives kept saying you got to take
some of the sugar home from you know
from here yeah take it back to your bar
i said i don't want sugar from here
remember she said no no no you gotta
take it look how cute it i took it back
and then i started reading the label
made you know
made in los angeles packaged in los
angeles
so i said well that's why they stopped
because they're shipping
cnh what was the one that we when people
loved sugar cnhc
um
are you seeing it from hawaii
no um oh that was cnnh sugar from hawaii
yeah that was a big commercial no no
what do you guys use over there dixie
crystal
what we own over there in miami it's all
about uh
cuban american sugar bearing she made me
cuban coffee
delicious chocolate for four days
i tried on my graduation suit from high
school and i almost butt
man that thing goes through you the
[ __ ] little alice in wonderland cup
and you're like what's this and they put
on oh let me put some sugar in it you
know
and it's the same coffee uh
yeah did he even make good good cuban
coffee
well she used a whisk i've never seen a
cuban use a whisk and then she had a
milk frother so you know she's got a
purist
i'm uh
i'm staying at eva longoria's house she
was that was she i gotta tell you she
gets an a for effort she gets an amazing
whisper and she
frothed yeah it's like there shouldn't
there's no whisks in cuban coffee
and i was like i want no wire whisk yeah
i don't want but you know that that
it's good it's not something you can
just
put together you have to have skill too
i loved it right but no didn't you drink
cuban coffee when you were married to a
cuban
i wouldn't do anything she told me to do
that's great
okay
okay guys i love you thank you for
coming i love you too anna navarro are
you coming to visit at some point yes of
course are you coming to uh i hope that
we end up working together for years and
years come to miami come see me i'll
come over
there
let me know how you how it is tonight
over there it should be fun yeah why
aren't you coming at the hollywood i'm
going to uh
to the la quinta
the um i'm gonna go play golf they said
hey when do you want to play when it's
110 or 114. you know you need to get
mark to invite you you know he's got a
farm in ocala in central florida yandeng
atvs he you know mark anthony goats are
born and he becomes like like farmer joe
and a puerto rican farmer joe and an atv
there's a lot of people
that i've met
in the time and a lot of people from
different worlds from music from
politics
uh on anal two and
mark anthony
is the person that
is maybe
the funniest the craziest yeah and the
all-around best dude and he
goes goes after it too he likes to drink
and you know tina come on you know he
wears all those chains just to keep him
held down
but he's he's a fascinating guy isn't he
i know man i was i was i was like
rooting i was like [ __ ] if jayla's gonna
recycle men can't she go back to mars
right i mean really you know that means
you just gotta give her a couple more
years
you know papi you know we were we were
at the he sang the
the national anthem for when de la hoya
fought mayweather and he had this little
pee-wee hermit suit like a little town's
tooth and he goes he goes
and he goes out there and just because
you see a guy in there goofing well i'm
scared jordan whatever i see i can't
sleep and you go out there and he just
kills it and you think man what what a
talented dude that yeah nothing gets to
him and uh and his voice
feels so clear i mean his passive arena
with like this incredible voice
from a guy who has
31 bud lights a day
i love you thanks for coming i love you
it was great to meet you thank you so
much for being here thank you all right
thank you everybody
you